[Music]
on this tuesday night the u.s president
responds to russia's moves
this is the beginning of a russian
invasion of ukraine the sanctions
imposed on russia how canada is
responding and the reaction from
ukrainians
denied bail the legal next steps were
some of the organizers of the so-called
freedom convoy
plus what ottawa endured and is trying
to overcome it was really brutal under
the weather with covent the queen scales
back some duties
and two plus two equals happy tuesday
the one-of-a-kind occasion on the
calendar
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the russian aggression in
ukraine canada has joined nato allies in
announcing sanctions against russia
denouncing vladimir putin's decision to
violate international law
make no mistake
this is a further invasion of a
sovereign state
and it is completely unacceptable
president joe biden today also accused
russia of starting an invasion he said
it was clear from vladimir putin's
speech yesterday that putin intends to
move even further into ukraine carving
out a chunk of the country
none of us should be fooled
none of us will be fooled
there is no justification
further russian assault in ukraine
remains a severe threat in the days
ahead
and if russia proceeds it is russia and
russia alone that bears the
responsibility
russian troops have already moved into
donetsk and luhansk in southeast ukraine
where russia has backed a bloody armed
rebellion for eight years putin calls it
a peacekeeping mission biden doesn't buy
that
russia's move supplies of blood and
medical equipment into position on their
border
you don't need blood unless you plan on
starting a war
about 150 000 russian troops remain
poised along ukraine's borders putin's
next moves aren't clear nor is whether
the sanctions including suspending a gas
pipeline from russia to europe will make
any difference jackson proskow begins
our coverage tonight
smoke billowed from a ukrainian power
plant outside the rebel-controlled areas
of luhansk
its territory still controlled by
ukraine
on land russia now recognizes as
independent and is prepared to take by
force
in moscow russia's parliament authorized
military action on foreign soil
we have been left no choice said the
deputy defense minister
president vladimir putin reasserted
demands that ukraine abandon hope of
joining nato demilitarize and seed
disputed territory conditions that are
impossible to meet this is a serious
escalation by russia and a flagrant
violation of international law
russia's attempt to redraw the map has
brought swift international response
this is the beginning of a russian
invasion of ukraine in washington
president joe biden announced a first
round of sanctions on russian banks on
russia's ability to borrow money and on
vladimir putin's closest allies who in
the lord's name does putin think gives
them the right to declare
new so-called countries
on territory that belonged to his
neighbors the eu sanctioned nearly every
single member of russia's parliament
germany suspended the controversial
nordstrom 2 pipeline cutting off a key
source of income and european dependents
for moscow if he invades for the rest of
his presidency russia will flounder
economically i will say that flat out
on the streets of kiev ukrainians remain
equally defiant
and if they will try to come here
they will be in hell putin's calculus
seems vastly different he questions
ukraine's very existence as a sovereign
nation and has since ordered the
evacuation of all russian diplomats from
ukraine
another ominous sign for a country
already on the brink
tonight it feels like any attempt at a
diplomatic solution is now over a
planned meeting between the u.s
secretary of state and russia's foreign
minister has been canceled and we've
learned the u.s is redeploying more of
its troops within europe to shore up the
baltic states another move meant to
deter future russian aggression donna
all right jackson thanks the sanctions
imposed today are intended to convince
putin to change course and avoid what
the u.s president calls the worst case
scenario our crystal gomencing just
crossed the ukrainian border into poland
tonight crystal what are you hearing
from people in the region
donna ukrainian leaders have been
waiting for tough sanctions to be
applied to russia the hope was that they
would have come sooner however if they
are tough enough and enough countries
act together they could limit how far
russia advances into ukraine as for the
mood of the people they almost seem more
united now
not only in levieve where we've just
come from but kiev as well they are
determined to keep up with their regular
life pushing away any notion of panic or
fear
if something will start well i'm too old
to fight but at least i'm still capable
to carry ammo but for people with
somewhere else to go it's hard to quiet
voices outside of the country an
international medical student tells us
his family is urging him to return to
india my parents are even very much
panicked
they always call come come and
[Music]
see your parents back home yeah they
don't want you to be in ukraine yeah
yeah what did they say to you
they only see the news channels and all
and they panic very much and how do you
feel
and not so much panic but due to my
parent issues i have to go india
foreigners are often reminded that
ukrainians have been engaged in an
ongoing war in the east for the past
eight years they say that ukraine is a
very large country and until the
conflict is at their doorstep
they refuse to be paralyzed by fear
donna
crystal commencing thanks well canada's
position mirrors that of the u.s that
the russian invasion of ukraine has
started it is the deputy prime minister
said today a test of our resolve and
that of our allies mercedes stevenson
has canada's reaction to all of this
mercedes
donna the tone here in the nation's
capital urgent and dire from the prime
minister and the top ministers from his
cabinet who were gathered around him
tonight during a press conference take a
listen to what prime minister justin
trudeau and deputy prime minister
christopher freeland had to say about
the situation in ukraine
canada and our allies
will defend democracy we are taking
these actions today
to stand against authoritarianism
people of ukraine
like all people must be free to
determine their own future
this is an attempt
to replace that rules-based
international order with a world in
which might makes right
where the great powers have the
authority to redraw the borders
dictate the foreign policies
and control the governments of sovereign
democracies
donna you could really feel the weight
there of the potential for a global
crisis here that the government was
underlining canada taking action falling
in line with what the united states has
done in terms of announcing sanctions
against russia those sanctions include
banning canadians from dealing
financially with the independent states
sanctioning the russian parliamentarians
who voted in favor of recognizing those
states banning canadians from purchasing
russian sovereign debt as well as
putting sanctions on two state-backed
russian banks and officials say that
this will escalate further if necessary
this is just the first round not
considered the invasion round if russia
goes further the sanctions will get
worse and could include canadian exports
mercedes canada is moving additional
troops to the region what can you tell
us about that
so 460 additional troops scheduled to go
in that includes a frigate a plane that
can detect submarines and do
intelligence on land as well as a
battery of artillery troops that's 120
people but it will take a month to
mobilize that last one
so certainly some concerns about both
the numbers being sent and how quickly
canada is capable of actually moving
donna
all right mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks
now to the aftermath of the weeks of
protest and disruption in the nation's
capital the trucks are out of the
downtown core and some of the organizers
have been denied bail at least for now
david aiken reports
even as she was being arrested freedom
convoy organizer tamara leach called on
her supporters to hold the line we'll
see you soon tamara hold the line
that and other calls to action leach
made during her three weeks at the
center of the occupation of ottawa were
at the heart of a judge's decision
tuesday to keep leach behind bars and
deny her bail request until her trial
begins on the single charge of
counseling to commit the offense of
mischief it is a charge which carries
the potential of 10 years or more in
prison
there is no doubt here the judge told
leach on conviction you are certainly
facing a potentially lengthy term of
imprisonment
convoy co-organizer pat king faces
similar charges he's been in jail since
he was arrested friday please step out
of the vehicle
prosecutors want to deny bail to king as
well a judge will decide on that on
friday
the proceedings in court occurred as
ottawa continued in recovery mode a
downtown core still under police
restrictions but largely free of any
protesters and while mps are back in
their ridings senators started debating
the federal emergencies act with a focus
on the fact that authorities have frozen
more than 200 personal and commercial
bank accounts containing a combined
seven million dollars they still need
the tools
the economic measures that are designed
to limit financial support for these
illegal blockades they continue to play
an important role
and even though officials said the
process has started to unfreeze some
accounts opponents say the government
has failed to provide the evidence
needed to justify such extraordinary
powers you know senator gold
you'll excuse some of us if we just
simply don't believe the rhetoric that
we are
being given by the government if a
majority in the senate do not support
the government's invocation of the
emergencies act any extraordinary powers
being used by law enforcement will
immediately cease
david aiken global news ottawa
researchers with the anti-defamation
league in the united states say several
hundred people who donated to the
so-called freedom convoy in canada also
donated to the january 6 demonstration
at the u.s capitol in washington the adl
analyzed information leaked by hackers
who accessed the crowdfunding platform
give send go it found 1100 people
donated to both the protests in canada
and the january sixth attempted
insurrection the biggest funder of both
campaigns was the editor-in-chief of a
far-right news website who contributed
more than three hundred thousand dollars
the adl says donating does not
necessarily mean support for violence or
extremism
all nearly two years after one of the
worst mass shootings in canadian history
an inquiry into the rampage began
hearings in nova scotia today it was in
april of 2020 that a lone gunman
disguised as a mountie killed 22 people
over a 13-hour period near the small
community of puerto pick the terror of
that day is long since over but the pain
and the loss for the victims families is
still raw ross lord reports
the commissioners conducting the public
inquiry say they're doing a thorough
investigation of the horrendous nova
scotia massacre public inquiries like
this commission
are powerful and flexible processes
their job is to discover exactly what
happened why it happened and how the
gunman was able to continue killing for
13 hours before police killed him a
rampage of horror that's left hundreds
of people in a string of communities
traumatized i didn't lose
my life that day you know there's 22
people did
but i lost the life that i had
daryl curry was almost killed at the
onslow fire hall by rcmp officers they
fired a series of shots after they
mistook someone for the gunman we want
answers to
how we got that fire and why you know
what happened in puerto pick what
happened
in glen home you know what happened in
plains road all of those other locations
most victims families are still too
shaken to speak publicly through their
lawyer they claim their secrecy
surrounding who will be called to
testify and whether their lawyers will
be able to question witnesses directly
questions about the inquiry extend
beyond victims families and others who
were traumatized among those also
expressing concerns is nova scotia's
premier concerns around you know the
completeness of the witness list the
ability to cross-examine and just make
sure that the questions that need to be
asked are being are being asked
including the rcmp's response their
failure to contain the gunman and their
inability to issue an emergency alert
for the public
policing analysts say it's crucial for
all canadians that the inquiry
identifies deficiencies and produces
improvements the rcmp have to have in
place a first responder strategy to deal
with an active shooter so that this type
of situation never occurs in canada at
least with the deadly results that it
did the commissioners insist the inquiry
will be transparent while considering
the needs of emotionally devastated
participants including those called to
testify beginning next week i don't have
a lot of faith in the inquiry curry
hopes in some way the outcome at least
helps him live with the aftermath
ross lord global news halifax
a correction now on a story we broadcast
january 7th in our covet 19 coverage we
reported the majority of
hospitalizations in ontario were
unvaccinated patients what we should
have said was the majority of cases in
intensive care were unvaccinated we
apologize for the error
coming up the queen's health what is
raising more concerns about how she's
doing
the queen has cancelled her virtual
engagements as she deals with covid19
two days ago buckingham palace announced
the 95 year old had tested positive
she's said to be experiencing mild cold
like symptoms though as redmond shannon
reports the virus is a concern for
anyone her age
a jubilee queen still in covert 19
isolation as outside windsor castle her
english subjects prepared to ditch the
last of their pandemic laws
despite the palace repeating that the
queen only has mild symptoms the news
that the 95 year old monarch canceled
all her online engagements on tuesday is
a concern to some it's obviously such a
worry for anyone to get covered but
particularly as we know it does affect
people who are older but thankfully the
queen is triple vaccinated so hopefully
she will have a mild dose and she'll get
over it very soon rachel loftus came to
windsor castle to receive a royal honor
for her services to the clinically
vulnerable during the pandemic only to
arrive when the queen herself was
isolating it was lovely that she wanted
to do some light duties but we would we
would encourage everyone to treat this
virus take it very seriously and look
after themselves i do think it's
significant that the palace have put out
a statement within a couple of days so
at least they're keeping us informed
royal commentator richard fitzwilliams
thinks the queen will be eager to get
back to work obviously her medical team
led by sir thomas are keeping a very
close eye on the on matters the palace
has not said when she will resume online
public duties from thursday people in
england with covid no longer need to
isolate but are advised to do so if they
can redmond shannon global news windsor
england
ahead a landmark win for the u.s women's
soccer team
in the u.s three men convicted of
murdering ahmed arbury who was unarmed
have been found guilty on all charges
the jury took less than four hours to
determine arbory was targeted because he
was black prosecutors revealed text
messages and social media posts
containing racial slurs and derogatory
comments about black people in 2020
arbory was jogging through a brunswick
georgia neighborhood when the defendants
chased him in trucks they cornered him
and one of the men fatally shot him
the three men who were already serving
life in prison now each face additional
life sentences
the u.s women's national soccer team
scored a major victory off the field
settling an equal pay lawsuit with the
soccer federation for 24 million dollars
the legal battle has gone on for six
years players allege gender
discrimination in nearly every aspect of
playing conditions even while
outperforming their male counterparts
we are really in the midst of an
incredible turning point in women's
sport this is just one step
in furthering our sport and getting the
the respect and the attention that we
deserve
the settlement includes a 22 million
dollar lump sum in back pay to the
players and two million dollars towards
players post career goals and other
charitable efforts the women's pay will
now be on par with the men's team
including world cup bonuses
next the quiet capital the roadblocks on
the return to normal in ottawa
in ottawa the protesters the honking and
the trucks are gone but some police
checkpoints are still in place mike
armstrong spent the day speaking to
people who have waited for weeks to get
back to regular life
it didn't quite feel like a regular day
but michael harness is very happy to be
back at work the brass street
metropolitan was closed for weeks and
hannes was stuck at home with protesters
outside the best way i can describe it
it was like there was a lawn mower in my
living room 24 hours a day and then we
got shot down here at work so we lost
three weeks of pay four weeks of pay so
it was terrible
this was the scene outside the brass
reef during the protest management did
open for valentine's day but says it
wasn't worth it financially or
emotionally we were still dealing with
the excess incessant noise the fireworks
the honking the drinking people
urinating and defecating on the patio
a lot of businesses in ottawa's byward
market stayed open during the protest
but lost money public transportation was
shut down meaning people couldn't make
it and a lot of the ones who could were
nervous
erica gary didn't close but he lost
about 80 percent of his customers people
were scared to come down
so we have minimum we basically we're
open
not to stay at home and go crazy
now life is still far from back to
normal the security zone around
parliament hill is smaller but it's
still a chunk of downtown that's
surrounded by an eight-foot fence and
police checkpoints it's just been insane
these men live in the security zone and
ventured out for the first time tuesday
still a little in shock it was it was
really brutal there was no police there
was no
neighbors were caring for each other
but we were forgotten
as if this area hadn't been through
enough there was a police operation on
this day the mall that's been closed for
three weeks was closed again for a
suspected armed shoplifter people who
had been out of work were out on the
streets
a lot of people in this city were
shaking their heads wondering what's
next the return to normalcy
isn't a straight line
mike armstrong global news ottawa
and that is global national for this
tuesday february 22nd a
once-in-a-lifetime date it is
22-22 a palindrome day because it reads
the same four words as backwards it's
also an ambergram because on a
calculator it can be read upside down in
exactly the same way
so it's both a tuesday and a tuesday
to some the lineup of twos is just
mind-blowing people are matching it with
temperatures with birthdays with
speedometers
and with time the ultimate is when the
clock hits 22-22 tonight for some
businesses it is a marketing dream toony
deals and a chance for a double-double
giveaway and it's an extra special day
for weddings thanks for watching take
care of yourselves bye-bye